why did he have to leave
he has always done it perfectly
but then D66 came with Mrs. Kaag
and then Bergkamp had to have 1 gift
because now it's just suddenly the friends politics again
nobody takes it seriously anymore
he himself didn't want to sit there tomorrow anymore
but that does not seem untouched to me
that 1 colleague who has been a gentleman for 24 years
has failed
We have been chosen twice as chairman from our midst
feels forced to do this with silent drum
leave the room
that she is now taking this decision
we all have to respect that
and yet it would be me
enormous virtue
if 1 way is sought
that there is still 1 possibility of saying goodbye
I have to confess the world
that it is not only 1 very pleasant colleague
but was also 1 particularly good chairman
and I think it's terrible that she
in this way
and has decided to stop
i also think i will 1 not make politics
but the reason for that
today's decision with Brazil
and to do the research
that that still affects
and that woman has to leave
that mountain side that controls the trick
it is 1 chairman of Jan liberick